this is a message from the government
[Music]
breaking news harry and megan have left
the royal family
this was a surprise to many of us who
have long suspected harry was never part
of it in the first place
like many woke people harry appears to
be compensating for his dodgy past
he famously attended a fancy dress party
in nazi costume
or as it's known in the family
granddad's uniform
like all good women megan has been
improving her husband by removing
all of his personality which in his case
is no bad thing
thanks to her harry now can't shut up
about oppression
which is always a great look for a
prince who better to educate the masses
on
honor and privilege than a man who was
born into royalty inherited wealth
and married a hollywood actress harry
has given up
all of his trappings of royalty although
megan has generously allowed him to keep
his official title
in the bedroom where she continues to
refer to him as princess
this marks a remarkable transformation
for harry a man who fought for his
country against the taliban
now fights his wife to be allowed to
stay up past his bedtime
there have been good times for the
couple as they did celebrate the birth
of baby archie despite his inherent
toxic masculinity
the couple were delighted to have a boy
as at least that means he'll be safe
from his uncle andrew
the queen is reportedly furious about
mexico
but let's be honest the old bat is
losing her touch
if megan tried to pull this [ __ ] 20
years ago she'd find herself
upside down in a paris tunnel faster
than she could say
is this limo electric but credit where
it's due
megan got her man to give up his status
his titles
and even his highly paid career in
ribbon cutting just so that the family
can finally
have some privacy and if you're
skeptical the privacy is what this is
really about
check out their exclusive interview with
oprah or stream their latest netflix
show
when harry met cocking
dick